hello while
MEPs are on summer break euros
by a tv presents the major
issues that await them here as soon as they
return from vacation last straight line
before the next European elections
in less than a year between May 22 and 25
2014 the citizens of the now 28
member states will elect their new
representative but before going to the
vote the deputies will not save they
will have to finalize a maximum of files
in the very last months of their
mandates
imagine
imagine that you are here at the
royal library of belgium
you think you are surfing the net
incognito and yet on the other side of
the web professionals collect the
slightest trace that you leave your
address and your telephone number there
when you participate in a contest your
hobbies on a social network or even where
sometimes your bank account number
not any fan of
american spy cases prism
exposed before holiday aug  lied
the concern of Internet users a
former consultant for the
American national security agency revealed that this
agency had had direct access to
private data on the Internet a
commission of inquiry of the parliament is
responsible for rendering its conclusions on
this case advances in  2013 here we are
in a field of miscanthus can you imagine
that this plant turns out to be an
excellent biofuel made up of
cellulose a food on the ground and which
flourishes on undoing in general
not very productive no direct competition
therefore with food contrary to
the use  corn, for example here in
the european parliament agrofuels
will also be at the heart of the discussions
from the start of the new school year
madam lepage hello hello what
do you propose to achieve a good
balance between economic interests and
ecological interests it's quite simple
limited and biofuels of the
first  generation which obliges
you to choose in driving and eating to
encourage those of the de  2nd way of
the third generation i.e.
those who do not
affect food see what projects us
into the future like algae which
could produce fuels and
give industry time to
s  adapt in such a way that there is
no impact on employment thank you we
also want to talk about health at the start of the school year
breast prostheses and prostheses two
years we were at the heart of recent
health scandals for European parliaments
their putting on the  market is
not monitored enough
up our purchasing movements for the
knicks the
fox must notify of stein stein
dynamics islam criminal in the event of a
crisis because the ganzau son benoît xvi the
fingers worries sarthe general
european in opening of the
qualifications
in this  band at j sery brussels
we find a wide range of
medical devices from simple dressings
to wheelchairs through
external prostheses my mother even if they
are certainly prostheses  Internal
Amazigh is what worries MEPs the most
That's it you have found the house of
your dreams
and to be able to buy it you
probably had to borrow money from your
bank unfortunately for some this
dream has turned into a nightmare
for the owners  were evicted
by their banks because they were
unable to repay their
loans harmonized legislation at
European level should better
protect future owners who want to
take out a mortgage loan
we do not need to have bac or
Europeans who no one  who met
in an independent territory
quite on the hip and
full valuation our corsican columns the
approach will count that we can think
waste sorting the vote in plenary
should take place in September
finally there will of course be again and
always question of the  exit from
crisis MEPs will have less than eight
months to strengthen the
financial and banking surveillance system
r  epart le tv wishes you a very
nice holiday